this is the San it is the only River
inside paris's ring and it cuts through
the Heart of the City
it links the most important landmarks
like the Eiffel Tower and Notre Dame and
it's also pretty disgusting on the 15th
of May in the year 1990 the mayor of
Paris and future president of France
Jacques Shirak made a promise
told Paris he would bathe in its most
disgusting River it was banned from the
public for almost 70 years but shiraka
was a man who wanted to lead France and
there weren't many political
achievements like getting French
citizens to swim in front of the Eiffel
Tower but Shirak was also a man of empty
promises
30 years after his TV announcement the
river is still off limits
2023 marks 100 years that the sand has
been forbidden but now there's a new
Parisian one who is promising the same
as Shirak
measure manifique
with the announcement of the 2024
Olympics the mayor of Paris has promised
that the sand will be cleaned paris's
River will be swimmable for the first
time in more than 100 years
so how does she aim to clean paris's
most disgusting River why and at what
cost
[Music]
Channel called Fern for as long as I've
been making videos I've also been
wanting to work with a team a team that
can produce videos faster trying to
increase the standards of what is
expected on YouTube and to also make
videos for people who live in Europe but
consume English content
for a while this was just a dream but
then I found the perfect people I heard
that there were two German guys who
lived in Amsterdam and made YouTube
videos so I locked myself in my
grandparents basement and got to work I
knew that Germans took their privacy
seriously so I hired private
investigators to scour the streets for
anyone with a German accent
and I spent days and nights researching
my girlfriend left me and my grandma
disowned me but it was worth it I found
their house and knocked on their door
and asked to start a YouTube channel
together
they were sweating a lot but they were
down so we got to work we made videos on
plane hijackings with no terrorists puts
in secret underground bunkers Rich
Germans with foundations named after
their Nazi parents and of course toilets
you can watch all of those videos right
now and a new one almost every week at
youtube.com Fern Dash TV
[Music]
teen Paris won the Olympic bid for 2024
different from all Olympics before it
paris's opening ceremony will not take
place in a stadium but instead it will
take place in the sand boats from each
National delegation will carry hundreds
of athletes across paris's River
but what makes the 2024 Olympics even
stranger are the plans to also use the
river for two Olympic events the
triathlon and Marathon swimming this
would have been Unthinkable only a
decade ago but now it was something's
different over the past couple of years
paris's mayor has been busy in a city of
around 600 000 parking spots she's
ordered the removal of 70 000 of them in
under three years she's closed off
streets to cars reduced lanes and also
speed limits
support Millions into adding hundreds of
kilometers of bike lanes and in 2021 she
adopted a 250 million euro plan to
transform the chandelier from a car
Centric Boulevard into an urban Forest
her government has pushed through
multiple plans for Greenup crates across
the city they're an investment to make
the city more pleasant but also safe to
live in as temperatures rise but they
also require capital and time
so for Hildago the Olympics were the
perfect opportunity to accelerate them
and to also justify their costs and if
there is one plan that hinges on the
Olympics like no other it's her plan for
the San
for the past few years Paris has been
undergoing a 1.4 billion Euro
infrastructure plan to make its River
swimmable
the Olympic events held in the sand will
not just make good entertainment but
they're also a massive televised PR
attempt to show the world it's clean
enough to swim in
it would be a historic achievement a
beautiful blue Jewel to top off the
mayor's already queen crown in a city
especially vulnerable to heat waves she
would give the city a chance to cool off
but to get her blue Jewel has been no
cheap and easy task what people don't
understand is that hildago's most
expensive plan is not her war on cars
it's her war on a much more elusive hard
to grab object human
[Music]
paris's sewer system is the ovioid pipe
instead of pumps the city sewer relies
purely on Gravity by harnessing the
natural incline of the Sand River Basin
the ovoid shape of the pipe concentrates
water flow and a slope of around three
centimeters per meter ensures a steady
flow of debris while making it possible
for maintenance staff to walk around
waste water funnels from a much denser
network of smaller ovioid pipes into a
handful of much larger collector sewers
collector sewers line the sand and they
direct sewage to Wastewater plants
Downstream of the city for its time
paris's sewer was an intellectual Marvel
but today it has an old problem the
sewer is a combined one it mixes storm
water and water together modern
sewage systems on the other hand are
usually built with separate drains for
both and the reason for doing this is
simple if you combine storm water and
water and suddenly you have a lot
of storm water there's a risk that the
entire sewer can flood if that happens
it can cause mixed storm water to
go back to where it came from
paris's sewer system wasn't entirely
unprepared for this though and its large
collector sewers are intentionally built
without fall pipes
in the case of a flood these pipes
direct waste water into an emergency
location
one small problem though is that in
paris's sewer the emergency location is
the sand
today 44 outfall pipes direct waste
water into the river around 12 times a
year only last year about 1.9 million
cubic meters of untreated Wastewater
went into the river
the Hildago wants the sand to be cleaned
she needs to change paris's sewer system
so over the last few years our
government has attempted just that and
Paris has been constructing a very big
tank and tunnel
the tunnel is around 700 meters long and
connects the current sewer system to the
cylinder tank which is around 50 meters
wide and 34 meters deep
at full capacity this tank will hold
around 45 000 cubic meters of storm
water and it's roughly the size of 20
Olympic swimming pools the aim is for
the tank and tunnel to fill up with
storm water before paris's entire sewer
system does eventually releasing the
water slowly back into the sewer system
without overflowing it the tank and
tunnel are expected to bring the
flooding from around 12 times a year to
three from 1.9 million cubic meters of
Wastewater annually to one hundred
thousand clearly this won't be a perfect
modification in cases of extreme rain
the river should still be avoided for
some days
the tank and tunnel are not large enough
to bring flooding to a guaranteed zero
but even if it did the city still has
other water sources it needs to
tackle as well
talked on the river are around 170 home
boats that dump their into the sand
daily in 2018 the city mandated that
these boats needed to be connected to
the Sewer but the people on board
weren't on board the Boat Owners felt
that the cost for fitting their ships to
the Sewer outweighed the benefits but on
the other hand maybe just don't in
a public River the only difference
between boat owners and a person who
stands on the side of the river and
takes a directly into it are a few
walls and a door
along with the home boats the city is
also trying to convince 23 000
homeowners on land to also connect with
the current sewer system but here there
are also problems
like the houseboats some homeowners
simply do not want to connect to the
sewer system either by July of 2023 only
25 percent of homeowners have been
connected even with the government
offering 6 000 Euros to each household
to help cover the costs
the construction of a giant tank and
tunnel were in some ways a lot more
straightforward than connecting a bunch
of individual homes as a final measure
the city has also been upgrading
Wastewater plants Upstream of the city
by adding small amounts of performanic
acid to the Wastewater the levels of
harmful fecal bacteria can be cut by a
hundred times alone each of these
measures are a far cry from perfect but
together they can be enough by 2025 the
city is on track to open up three pools
in the sand each with their own
lifeguards changing rooms and demarcated
swimming areas these pools can be found
within the ring and are named things I
couldn't be bothered to pronounce for
this video
the city is also considering more than
20 other sites that can also be
converted into swimming areas in the
future
now whether hildago's plans will succeed
is not going to be determined by
YouTubers or pundits it will be
determined by time will Paris turn into
a green Cream City and Hildago
celebrated as a leader who got it right
or will it be underwhelming a lot of
money for things that looked much cooler
in 3D renders than they do in reality
I don't know but what I do know is that
France has been at the Forefront of
sustainability for a while now for
example they forced McDonald's to use
reusable dishware requiring expensive
design teams to make very unique
reusable designs that reduce the use of
single-use plastic the story is
fascinating and you can watch the video
on it right now on Fern using the link
on screen
foreign